Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier...
...and welcome to Dungeon Nightmares.
[beep]
It is dark. I don't have a flashlight...
...but that says "Press C to Use".
And now it says "Press B to Blow".
[beep]
"She's coming!"
Do I need to press B to blow?
[beep]
Hiii!
I'm gonna call you Boney!
You want me to press B to blow?
[beep]
"I wouldn't look in the mirror."
Where's a mirror? AAAAHFFFF...uck you, dickbag!
You just lost your B-to-blow privileges.
[beep]
"Don't follow her to that room."
Oh, really? Did she hear about my b-to-blow skillz?
[beep]
You know, that red text, when it says...
..."Artifact is found", makes me think that...
...I might die soon.
I MIGHT DIE SOON!
"I will always be with you..."
NO THANK YOU!
[beep]
Are you the same Boney as the other Boney?
I gotta turn around to open this door--HASDFDSGHRRR
I was so hideously ugly that the second I looked at him...
...he DIED.
[beep]
What? Whywhywhy?
Wh-whywhywhywhywhywhywhy?
HEUGH!
Whywhywhywhy?
Why? Why do I keep black out t--WAAAAHAA!
"Press C to Use"
...and now it says "Press B to Blow".
Rrreally?
...it's also for butts!
Which I'm gonna stab of the maker of this game.
I'm gonna stab him in the butt...
STOPITSTOPITSTOPITSTOPITSTO--
This is a violent game.